flight tracking data showed a C-17 Royal
Air Force transport plane heading it
seemed towards Sudan into Sudanese
airspace it didn't show where it landed
but we understand that this aircraft was
carrying a team of British troops a
reconnaissance team on the ground in
Port Sudan which is a port on the Red
Sea Coast in the east of Sudan it's more
than 500 miles from the capital Khartoum
which is as you can see from these
images the heart of this Fierce fighting
over the last week and a half that's LED
left hundreds of people dead forced
residents to hide terrified in their
homes and triggered this huge
International effort to rescue diplomats
from the capital and also then work out
how to rescue large numbers of foreign
Nationals that are trapped in Khartoum
and want to get out so we've heard from
the Armed Forces Minister James heapey
um just now saying that the job is not
yet done the ministry of Defense
um was part of this big Rescue Mission
over the weekend a dramatic Mission it's
very dangerous to operate it in Khartoum
and British aircraft flew to an Airfield
north of the capital flying from an air
base in Cyprus and then an elite team
had flown in beforehand I understand
with the Americans they'd gathered
together the British diplomats and their
families in Khartoum and then managed to
extract them through multiple
checkpoints armed guards all over the
place to the Airfield and then get them
out clearly it's high risk and to do
that again to get out these British
Nationals these many British Nationals
up to the thousands is incredibly
dangerous so all of these options
um may be an evacuation by C maybe
evacuation by air maybe asking allies to
help evacuate British Nationals or maybe
deciding it's better to stay in place
all of these things are being considered
and I can read to you some words from
James heathy which kind of helps to give
you a sense of the thinking that's going
on inside government at the moment
inside the ministry of Defense in
particular about how work is underway to
give the Prime Minister and this Cobra
emergency committee options for what
could be done to support the wider
community of British Nationals in Sudan
these options are being developed at
PACE and the prime minister is going to
be given the option to take any of the
options that are presented to him so
this team that have flown into Port
Sudan today are a reconnaissance mission
there's no sense of any imminent rescue
that's important to stress this is just
British troops working out what options
could be presented to the Prime Minister
I also understand that a British warship
HMS Lancaster it's a a frigate it's in
or near the region and potentially it
could be an asset that the UK government
could use but like I said these are just
options for now no decision yet but
clearly a lot of work going on